ce
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce set 8
l'aktu qui fait le tour d'horizon de
votre information locale et quelques
mots de politique pour débuter cette
édition est la campagne des municipales
à maurepas qui connaît un énième
rebondissement avec tout d'abord hervé
miclo l'actuel adjoint au maire délégué
à la culture a décidé de rejoindre la
liste de pierre le guérinel le candidat
de l'udps et y membres du parti
socialiste hervé nicod avait sollicité
l'investiture de sa formation mais
ismaila one le conseiller général lui a
été préférée il a donc décidé de quitter
le ps et de s'engager sur une autre
liste autre ralliement à pierre
leguérinel ancien premier adjoint de
cette mandature qui s'achève celui de
nagy de bâches
le représentant de debout la république
retire sa candidature et justifie sa
démarche pour une volonté d'optimiser
les chances de réussite du changement à
maurepas
il ajoute soutenir l'investiture d'une
de ses ancienne colistière dr ndlr dans
cette liste d'union
en revanche et malgré les demandes de
l'ue dei et de l'ump pas d'alliance pour
pierre leguérinel et grégory gary astier
le représentant de la droite ce local
vient de déposer sa liste sans
l'investiture de son parti
valérie pécresse n'a donc pas réussi à
le convaincre l'ump des yvelines se
divise sur cette candidature depuis
plusieurs mois du sénateur gérard
larcher à l'ancien député jean michel
fourgous
actuellement cette liste devrait donc
être en mesure de se présenter devant
les électeurs à maurepas et elles
viendront sur ce plateau débattre ce
sera le 11 mars à 20 heures demain 22
février c'est la journée mondiale du
scoutisme alors créée en 1907 par robert
baden powell le scoutisme représente
aujourd'hui 40 millions de membres à
travers le monde
en france on en dénombre près de 70000
trois sont avec nous aujourd'hui je
commence par les dames anne mousse tard
assistante commissaire de district pour
les louveteaux des scouts d'europe
bonjour anne bonjour olivier caroline
boucher chef plein de groupes yvelines
toujours pour les scouts d'europe
bonjour caroline devant jean olivier est
un garçon à ma gauche samuel rossé
responsable pôle pédagogique des scouts
et guides de
ans bonjour saluer l'homme dont olivier
je rappelle les effectifs dans les
yvelines 5500 membres pour les scouts
d'europe dans les yvelines 4500 membres
dans les yvelines pour les scouts et
guides de france
déjà c'est quoi la différence entre
scouts d'europe
à ma droite et scouts de france scouts
et guides de france vous laisse répondre
les filles d'abord alors les scouts
d'europe sont présents dans 19 pays
européens et le canada voilà c'est une
des grandes différences
je vois aussi au niveau des uniformes il
ya des différences samuel c'est quoi les
particularités c'est que nous en tout
cas au niveau des scouts et guides de
france on a un uniforme qui changent en
fonction de notre tranche d'âge et un
foulard qui changent en fonction du lieu
sur lequel on vit le scoutisme
alors justement pour détailler un peu
cet uniforme que représente-t-il le
foulard la chemise les insignes par les
eaux un petit peu accès par rapport à ça
un tuba je commence du coup nous on est
sur des couleurs donc on a plusieurs
tranches d'âge notamment les 8 11 ans
qui ont une couleur de chemise orange
les 11-14 une couleur de chemises bleues
les 14-18 rouge
les compagnons vers et en violet c'est
ce qu'ils ne sont plus en responsabilité
directe de jeunes mais qui accompagna
notamment les et chefs et cheftaines
dans leurs missions sur cette chemise on
a différents un signe qui nous rattache
d'abord aux mouvements scouts et guides
de france
ensuite au scoutisme français au stick
scoutisme mondial pardon et auggie
disque mondiale
on a un insigne de promesses soit un
signe d'engagement qui est une action
qu'on fait volontairement pour adhérer
aux valeurs du scoutisme et l'on
s'engage à les porter c'est là qu'on
voit là c'est celui là d'accord qu'il
manquait sur le coeur ces scouts et
guides de france ont le porte côté
gauche il me semble que chez vous c'est
sur le chapeau nous avons 6
il accroche du prêtre pour expliquer les
différentes tranches d'âge puisque
justement elle varie entre scouts et
guides de france et scouts d'europe
un petit mot and sur les différentes
tranches d'âge alors nous nous avons
gardé le le schéma de l'ordre baden
powell de garder que trois tranches
d'âge le créateur de scoutisme
oui comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
on a les 8 11 ans les louvettes et les
louveteaux donc qui eux ont une chemise
bleu clair à à manches courtes
on a aussi les doses 17 ans les guides
et les scouts puis les aînés 18 ans ou
plus donc les routiers guides aînées et
tous les chefs et cheftaines en service
et pour les aînés et les guides et
scouts on a des chemises à manches
courtes à manches longues pardon bleu
clair pour les filles et belges pour les
garçons et tous tous les chefs ont des
pantalons alors que les plus jeunes ont
des os des bermudas et en fait
l'uniforme chez nous permet aussi de
devoir vraiment à qui on s'adresse
parce qu'on a des tas de d'insignes et
qui indique vraiment précisément qui on
est la fonction qu'on a
d'où vient donc sur la manche droite on
à l'écusson de la provence
la bombe de groupe qui indique à quel
groupe on appartient de quelle ville on
vient et c'est on a quand on a des
fonctions de chef nous avons des bancs
de des pôles qui indique donc quelles
sont ses fonctions parce qu'en fonction
de la fonction on n'a pas la même bande
on est un foulard qui indique soin de
notre unité donc moi j'ai le foulard par
exemple de des guides aînées donc toutes
les guides aînées ont le même foulard
que moi mais j'ai aussi d'autres
d'autres foulard en fonction des
deux des casquettes que je prends en
tout cas déjà la qualification sur les
sur les uniformes et les différences
entre les différents types de scouts
alors il ya sept ans nous fêtions le
centenaire du scoutisme est ce que en un
siècle caroline beaucoup de choses ont
changé comment on peut définir le
scoutisme aujourd'hui le scoutisme c'est
une formidable aventure très
enthousiasmante qui est un vrai projet
de vie et ça je pense que ça n'a pas
changé lorsque on prononce sa promesse
enfin scotto une guide prononce sa
promesse il promet d'obéir à une loi en
plusieurs articles et cette loi elle est
valable dans sa vie en unités
lorsqu'ils pratiquent le scoutisme mais
c'est valable à la maison à l'école etc
et ça je pense que les valeurs
fondamentales n'ont pas changé ce sont
voilà ces valeurs moi j'avais
l'apprentissage de la ville esprit d
équipe le partage samuel c'est ça le
scoutisme c'est ça et c'est en fait
c'est ce sont des mouvements d'éducation
populaire qui apporte une éducation
complémentaire à l'éducation de la
famille à l'éducation de l'école qui
enseigne d'abord un savoir-faire sur la
débrouillardise en forêt le lien avec la
nature apprendre à se débrouiller à
cuisiner faire des brocolis par exemple
c'est pas forcément évident et ensuite
tout un savoir être notamment par ses
valeurs de respect de partage
d'entr'aide avec la vie en équipe aux
petites équipes puis dans une unité
complète où on apprend à vivre ensemble
et à avancer ensemble sur des projets
le scoutisme ânesse qu'il est bien vu
aujourd'hui par lennon scouts les
non-initiés quel retour vous avez vous
des gens quand vous êtes en uniforme
comme ça avec vos patrouille mais c'est
vrai que les lions sont souvent un nous
posent des questions nous montrent
justement par rapport à l'uniforme qui
est qui sommes-nous ce qu'on fait
donc les gens de plus tendance justement
à nous poser des questions elle
s'intéressait vraiment à ce qu'on fait
donc ça c'est vraiment positif et
et non les les gens connaissent
connaissent et ont une bonne
un bon point de vue du scoutisme donc en
général on est vraiment très bien
accueilli en général un retour plutôt
positif êtes d'accord
le relief samuel aussi c'est pareil
voilà d'accord un seul retour qui sont
en fait plus marrant que négatif c'est
que quand on se promène dans la rue on
se fait siffler tout le monde de crise
que toujours parce que cette session ci
au fil de de gérard jugnot alors dans le
scoutisme a forcément une connotation
religieuse
la croyance est importante est-ce que
c'est véritablement important est ce que
c'est un frein pour quelqu'un qui n'est
pas baptisé par exemple pour accéder au
scoutisme à ce que ça peut être un frein
non pas du tout je pense que j'ai les
guides et scouts d'europe on accueille
tout le monde dans la mesure où les les
familles et les jeunes qui nous sont
confiées sont d'accord avec notre projet
pédagogique et adhèrent à ce projet la
voile en fait c'est ça c'est pas
forcément adhérer à une croyance est un
projet pédagogique il faut adhérer à ce
projet leur voilà d'accord alors pour
terminer de façon sympathique ce petit
entretien ont déjà merci pour toute
explication juste réjouit samuel à petit
truc d'ailleurs vous avez dit que nous
étions 70 milles scouts en france ont
fait ton et 150 mille 150 170 la miss
est respectée de france mais merci pour
cette petite précision samuel je vous le
disais on termine avec un petit quizz
sur le scoutisme un petit quizz culture
générale scouts déjà que signifie le
terme scouts
est ce que vous le savez éclaireur pour
moi bonne réponse de samuel bonnes
réponses un petit point pour pour samuel
la naissance de robert baden powell
alors une estimation tout du moins moi
je dirais en 52 1852 1852 c'est pas loin
c'est pas loin et 860 aller 1857 et à 50
ans donc il crée le scoutisme en 1907
les scouts ouvrent leurs portes au fis
en quelle année on a des filles sur ce
plateau c'est une salle et en quelle
année fille sont autorisés chez les
scouts
dans les années 50 mais c'est plus tard
salue avec 64 pour moi 1982 ou sitter si
tard que ça eh oui oui 1990 1982 en
quelle année on en parlait tout à
l'heure le film scout toujours 2es avec
gérard jugnot sortie là en quelle année
c'est pas très loin de la date de
l'arrivée des filles ouais 1986 85 voilà
c'est la dernière question là l'année de
la journée pardon du scoutisme c'est
toujours le 22 février qu'elle saintes
fêtes dont le thème est la visite
d'elizabeth i la veille qui est un très
beau prénom et j'en profite d'ailleurs
pour saluer ma maman qui s'appelle
isabelle meiffren aussi la belle
merci à vous d'être venu sur ce plateau
merci caroline merci à mr samuel est ce
que vous faites du vélo ça vous arrive
alors est ce que vous connaissez garé à
st ce nom alors guerriers saints c'est
un jeune entrepreneur de 30 ans il y a
cinq ans il fonde une société
spécialisée dans la vente de pièces
détachées deux vélos désormais avec une
20 millions de chiffre d'affaires il
veut s'exporter à l'étranger un
reportage d' anthony rech et détiennent
langues
quand on voit gary marché dans les
allées de son stock
on n'imaginerait pas une seule seconde
que dix ans plus tôt ce compétiteur de
vtt au niveau national et européen chuté
lourdement lors d'un entraînement suis
cassé la colonne vertébrale j'ai été
immobilisé un peu plus d'un an j'ai
découvert internet et le e-commerce
à ce moment là parce que je pouvais plus
bouger et de ma passion en fait j'essaie
transposer ça sur un modèle commercial
dans le e-commerce et l'aventuré n'est
en mai 2008 donc autour du vélo c'est
donc de son lit que gary se lance dans
la vente de pièces détachées accessoires
pour vélos et donne naissance à ault
rixe avec seulement 6000 euros
six mille c'est aussi le nombre de
mètres carrés sur lesquels est désormais
installé son entreprise
aujourd'hui hall tricks et 45 salariés
dix sept mille références en stock et un
chiffre d'affaires en 2013 de 20
millions d'euros à 30 ans gary compte
bien passer au braquet supérieur
la majeure partie de l'activité est
concentrée sur la france aujourd'hui
et le challenge pour 2014 ces deux
d'avancé sur des pays comme le portugal
l'espagne l'italie où il ya peu de sites
internet dans le vélo aujourd'hui et
pour autant beaucoup de pratiquants
consécration pour l'entreprise de gary
après le vélodrome nationale hall trick
sera partenaire d'aso pour le tout
premier rock paris où se donneront
rendez-vous des milliers de vététistes
du 28 au 30 mars prochain à mantes la
jolie
et après le cyclisme le football
américain avec demain la reprise du
championnat de france élite de foot us
et les templiers d'elancourt qui
peaufinent leur combinaison et cette
saison ils sont prêts à aller chercher
le titre national avec leur nouvelle
recrue américaine que nous découvrons
dans ce sujet d' anthony rech et
jonathan wheelman
il est la nouvelle gâchette des
templiers le jeune quarterback américain
shaun shelton a débarqué à elancourt
tout droit du missouri il ya trois
semaines il va avoir la lourde tâche de
faire oublier le phénomène vini roth
s'est bien intégré dans l'équipe il
annonce bien il peut courir c'est ce
qu'on attendait c'est ce qu'on avait vu
sur les vidéos lorsqu'on l'a recruté
donc pas de mauvaises surprises
voilà on est on est très content il a
fait un bon match amical la semaine
dernière cette saison mickaël marion
s'occupe de la ligne d'attaqué manu
charest de la défense une nouvelle
organisation qui n'a qu'un seul but
l'objectif clairement ces finales et
titre pour faire mieux que l'an dernier
on s'arrêter en demi-finale où on a
perdu de peu contre le flash nous a
laissé un petit goût amer je pense
qu'avec les recrues d'intersaison
le reste de l'effectif qui restent
inchangées et stable je pense qu'on a
les landes d'atteindre cet objectif
après un début de saison idéal l'an
passé avec cinq victoires en autant de
journées des templiers avait connu un
énorme trou d'air et trois défaites
consécutives qui leur avait coûté la
première place en 2014 avec un
championnat réduit à neuf équipes
ils ne devront pas se louper la cuy
matches cette année encore vraiment pas
le rend pas le choix c'est pas le droit
à l'erreur n'y a pas de joker cette
année premier acte ce samedi sur le
terrain des kangourous de pessac
c'est la fin de ce set 8 lecture retour
de l'information locale lundi avec
wilfrid richie je vous laisse entre les
mains de clerck en biais pour le 7-8
week-end excellente soirée sur tv fil 78